this is special edition in the world of
show business we don't often get to say
this
four happily married people on the couch
not to each other the jones is not
related in any way
so i need to make an announcement before
so ryan uh you and blake can be married
for
uh oh god don't do this to me two two
three uh four years
three years are you guessing
three years
yeah four three and a half yeah
you just go yeah
okay good luck with getting to four
[Applause]
and catherine michael you've been
together a long time now fifteen uh
together seventeen married fifteen uh
will and jade
together 22 married 18. wow very good
but toby and karen beat you all uh
together 26 married one
now
what happened there
like were you saving
[Laughter]
i wanted to be really nice i wanted to
be really nice now what happened uh well
i think sorry this is none of my
it's business
uh
well we we proposed and accepted about
three or four times and uh every time
you know i proposed once yeah let's do
that let's do that and then
yeah we'll do that
and then the next time nothing happened
the next time she proposed to me on a
leap year and i said yeah absolutely you
know
nothing happened
and then the third time i proposed again
nothing happened then we said we've got
to stop proposing yes
we knew how to do it obviously but we
didn't agree how to do it as it were
we're still talking about getting
married now yes it is
[Laughter]
it seemed like a good thing to do very
good and of course ryan my beautiful
blake sexiest man in the world all those
things and yes she is the sexiest man
yeah
he's doing well there that's a good shot
right there look at you look at you
beautiful and happy yeah so annoying
yeah
no but to cheer us up when you started
kind of being interested in girls you
weren't as that cool or smooth with it
no no no not at all i don't believe it
no no i really i went through puberty at
like 27.
this is a freak thing yeah it was not
good yeah
who's the girl who was the girl in
school the first the first girl the
first well i was obsessed with this this
girl uh uh fiona gorczynski who uh uh
she's
and she used to actually she used to
take the bus the the the opposite way of
my actual home and i would get on the
bus just to sit next to her wow for 45
minutes the wrong way oh there's
something wonderful about there was
something
when you're young it's so cute when
you're older it's just stalking
you're like on some kind of watch list
yeah but but i remember when i was i
couldn't have been more than i don't
know 11 years old
and i i was just about to get off the
bus because enough is enough i'm about
to enter like seattle or something so
i'm starting to get off the bus and i
decided to like kind of hit her with
like this cool look or something like
this like one of these like real sort of
don johnson miami
[Laughter]
and i sort of delay a little too long
and the bus doors close on my backpack
with my backpack and the bus just starts
to leak
like banging on the side of the bus the
bus driver finally stops opens the door
let's releases my you know idiot bag
backpack and i i could never look at her
again
yeah that was terrible yeah she's
looking at you now
can you imagine she's like he's the guy
with the backpack
and people you know couples when they
meet together like they have little
rituals and ways to keep the
relationship fresh but you have one
involving golf is this right yeah that
old
thing yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty good i
think i can handle this oh no yeah i can
i can i can kick his ass in golf if i
say okay wow but don't you make these
bets when you're playing golf yeah if he
duffs the shot and can't get uh
um his ball um over the ladies tee he
has to take his pants off
don't drop them on the pitch on their
own
[Laughter]
but expose himself in some way yeah does
he do it's not just my husband it's any
man i play with
you
i have questions too
you know
drop them on the course what are
paparazzi doing all day
no there has been an issue with
paparazzi but i made him go into the
bushes and drop his pants
you're kind of you know real hollywood
couples are a power couple now married
18 years that's my wife though
still interesting look at that
[Laughter]
like i'm still breastfeeding
that's a girl
that's a good thing that's my wife
me there is no us and them it's we you
know i'm i'm a member of the academy at
home all the time driving my wife nuts
it's them you know it's that voice the
inner world
divided by fear